hi I'm Toby and welcome back to another
video today I'd like to show you through
some of the early works of Isaac Newton
these are very important contributions
to science and mathematics made while
Newton was quarantined at home during
the Great Plague of London this was a
plague that went from 1665 to 1666 it
was spread by fleas and killed around a
hundred thousand people over the course
of 18 months Newton had been studying at
Cambridge University and had just
obtained his degree in 1665 when the
university had to close as a precaution
against the plague so Newton returned
home to wolves for mana and over the
next two years there developed his
theories on calculus optics and
gravitation it is at this home where the
now famous apple tree is located 1666
was Newton's a year of Wonders he was
aged 23 at the time and he later said
that in those days I was in the prime of
my age for invention and minded
mathematics and philosophy more than at
any time since in this video I would
just like to focus on the work Newton
did during this time on the topic of
calculus and these pages are printouts
from the Cambridge University digital
library so the links for you to see the
originals yourself will be in the
description this first document written
by Newton and dated October 1666 has
come to be called the 1666 tracked on
fluxions it is the first collection of
Newton's ideas on calculus it is dated
in a different ink so this date could
have been added later on and there was
quite a rivalry between Newton and
Leibniz over who first described
calculus but regardless this document is
a collection of Newton's ideas since
1665 which can also be seen scattered
through his
earlier notebooks it says to resolve
problems by motion these following
propositions are sufficient he then lays
out a bunch of propositions and does
some examples to newton calculus was all
about in motion and he was trying to
understand motion because the physics
problems he was also working on required
some kind of mathematical base such as
for gravitation neither Newton nor live
nets were the first to completely come
up with calculus
they were both building upon the work
done by earlier mathematicians such as
Descartes let's work through this
demonstration here ourselves to see what
was going on we're going to think about
the motion of a moving particle so at
one moment in time we could describe the
position of the particle with an x and a
y these coordinates Newton would later
go on to call fluence
as they are flowing quantities and what
we want to know is how we would describe
this particle after a small period of
time so if it has moved to here we would
describe its X position as being X plus
some new quantity and likewise in the Y
direction to find how much it has moved
we would find the velocity of the
particle and multiply it by the small
change in time
Newton refers to velocities in two
directions as being P and Q and he uses
o to denote a very small infinitesimal
change in time so in the X Direction we
would write this as P times o Oh is not
equal to zero but it is very small so
after this change in time our X has gone
to X plus P oh and our Y has gone to y
plus Q Oh
instead of using P and Q Newton would
later go on to use X dot and Y dot as
the velocities and he would call these
the fluxions but that would have to wait
until a 1671 rewrite of this work we can
see it in Newton's notes here he says if
the described lines be x and y in one
moment a will be x + p au + y + qo in
the next Newton n does a demonstration
where the relation between lines x and y
is X cubed minus a B X plus a cubed
minus D Y squared equals zero he says I
may substitute X plus P o + y + qo into
the places of x + y to expand something
like this he would have used the
binomial expansion theorem which he also
had a hand in developing I will denote
these zeros here with a line through
them to make sure that they aren't
confused with these O's in here which
are not equal to zero
Newton then writes out the result of
this expansion and he says that since we
know X cubed minus a DX plus a cubed
minus D Y squared was zero we can find
those terms in our expansion and cancel
them out and then he writes the result
of doing that the next step is to divide
every term by oh and were able to do
that since oh is never actually equal to
zero and this is what we get Newton then
says also those terms are infinitely
little in which o is therefore omitting
them their wrists and he gives the
solution so if we cancel all of our
terms with an O and it
being so small that they're not going to
contribute then we get the same solution
that Newton gets and it is our time
derivative of what we started with
remember that this is a derivative with
respect to time so it's like we had
differentiated this implicitly X cubed
has become 3x squared times P which is
DX DT that is exactly what you would get
differentiating this and taking into
account that x and y are functions of T
this technique was a little
controversial because o is treated both
as being not zero and close enough to
zero to cancel out and nowadays we use
the notation of limits to make it more
rigorous we would say that in the limit
of o going towards zero this term would
go towards zero now this whole
demonstration here was actually a
demonstration of proposition seven so
why don't we have a look back at
proposition seven to see what it was
proposition seven starts here and it
talks about having an equation
expressing the relation between two or
more lines XY and Z and the relation of
their velocities P Q and R may be found
by putting all the terms on one side of
the equation so that they are equal to
nothing and first multiply each term by
how many times P over X as X have
dimensions in the terms and let's work
through what he's doing here we're going
to start with the same equation that we
had before and we'll find its derivative
this way which is the same as saying the
relation of the velocities so we times
each term by P over X for how many
dimensions of X it has so for example
this first term has three dimensions of
X so we will do X cubed times three
times P
X the second term has one dimension of X
the third and fourth terms had zero
dimensions of X so we were times it by
zero times P over X which is the same as
multiplying it by zero so I'm not going
to write it down he says that secondly
multiply each term by how many times Q
over Y as Y has dimension in it so we do
the same thing now for y the first three
terms have zero dimension than Y so they
would be multiplied by zero but this
last term has two dimensions of Y so he
would times it by two times Q over Y if
you had a third variable you would keep
going
he says the sum of all of these products
shall be equal to nothing yet so it's
equal to 0 and the equation gives the
relation of the velocities so if we tidy
this equation up this X will cancel with
one of the X's up there and we will get
3x squared times P these X's here will
cancel we'll get a B P one of the Y's
will cancel we'll get minus 2d y Q
equals to zero and indeed this is the
time derivative of what we started with
and it was a quicker method than the one
we just did before but it's the same
result I find that really awesome that
we were able to actually follow along
with Newton as he's doing some
derivatives and we can see at the end
here that he gives us a general form for
doing this later in the document he goes
on to apply these theorems to resolving
of problems you can see here he's
drawing tangents to crooked lines and
over here problem five is to find the
nature of the crooked line whose area is
expressed by any given equation
that is the nature of the area being
given to find the nature of the crooked
line whose area it is and all this talk
of area might remind you of integration
and Newton does go on to really talk
about the link between differentiation
and integration and finding the area
beneath a curve
he seems aware that these two things are
inverses and that is the fundamental
theorem of calculus this is another
document written by Newton but at a
later time and I just wanted to show it
to you because it shows that he does
later go on to use the terminology
fluxions where instead of using P and Q
for the velocities he uses X dot and Y
dot but the rest of the examples here
are the same fluxions were kind of
central to the whole Leibniz Newton
controversy and in fact the last
document I would like to show you is a
litter in Latin that Newton wrote to
Leibniz via another middle man called
Henry Oldenburg and this was dated the
24th of October 1676
and in it Newton explains functions but
actually conceals his words in code
because he was so suspicious of Leibniz
around here he says I cannot proceed
with the explanation of the flexions now
I have preferred to conceal it thus and
then he puts this random string of
numbers and litters and it looks a bit
like a Bitcoin address but actually it's
an incited phrase and this phrase here
defines the relationship between the
fluent and inflection
now what he did to get this was he took
the phrase in Latin saying given an
equation that consists of any number of
flowing quantities to find the flexions
and vice-versa he'd encountered the
frequency of each litter and ordered
them alphabetically if there were three
or more
of a letter then he would put a number
in front so it looks like there were six
days and nine ends even if Leibniz could
decode this the phrase doesn't seem to
show much although it must have given
Newton some kind of security over the
idea the fact he could put it down on
paper and make a claim in this fight
about his ideas being stolen this issue
of ownership became so complicated
because Newton's work on fluxions and
calculus and many other things wasn't
published until a long time after he
wrote it even Leibniz work wasn't
published straight away and I thought
this little document here would be a
nice insight into the relationship
between the two men so that's been a
look at some of Newton's original work
even as a math student I don't think I
had really seen much of his original
thinking so I hope you found this video
a little bit interesting you can go to
the links in the description to the
Cambridge University digital library to
see these documents as well as many more
about Newton this video was made
possible by my viewers who support me on
patreon so if you'd like to help me
continue making videos like this then
please consider supporting me there too
it's patreon.com slash Toby's a big
thank you to my current patrons and a
special mention to today's patreon cats
of the day gandalf the grey and bo
[Music]
[Music]